après tout ce que vous avez vu dans le
monde
[Musique]
dites-nous à quoi servent les Hunger
Games
les jeux sont là pour punir les
districts
cette tribu n'ont pas le choix
votre rôle est de transformer ses
enfants en bête de scène pas en
survivant
nous sommes en direct souriez c'est pour
ça qu'on a des dents
et à la moisson
se soucie un peu de moi comme si j'avais
encore de la valeur
bienvenue au Capitole on dirait que tu
n'es pas à ta place ici en effet mais je
suis ton mentor un rebelle
vous voulez protéger les gens
alors il est essentiel d'accepter ce que
sont les êtres humains
ce que ça engendre de les contrôler
voyons de quelle façon snow se sert de
son célèbre charme
tu as l'air d'être un gars
j'ai vu ce que la guerre a fait
aujourd'hui
par l'angoisse de devenir une proie
voyez à quelle vitesse on devient un
prédateur
je veux que mes ennemis regardent un
arc-en-ciel de destruction
engloutir le monde
bonne chance avec ce pauvre oiseau
chanteur où est-elle
c'est un mystère et les mystères ont le
temps de rendre les gens dingue
monsieur snow laissez-moi vous poser la
question une dernière fois à quoi
servent les Hunger Games
[Musique]
ce sont les choses auxquelles nous
tenons le plus qui nous détruisent